tengo aquí una matriz a que es una
matriz de n por n y esta matriz pues en
este en este vídeo lo vamos a escribir
de esta forma vamos a escribir nada más
sus filas tiene una primera fila luego
tiene la segunda fila y la 3 ferrer a
fila y así hasta que llegamos a la
décima fila después tiene más filas
hasta que llegamos a la fila j
esto es una r y finalmente llegamos a la
última fila que es la enésima fila ok a
qué me refiero con estos con estos
vectores pues cada uno de estos vectores
es un vector fila y vamos a escribir uno
con detalle para que sepa exactamente
qué me refiero digamos que tenemos la
que es y más fila y es acá décima fila
aquí le estamos representando con un ere
k gay
r que no es nada más que un vector de
esta forma donde la primera entrada es a
estamos en la calle décima fila entonces
es aa1 la segunda entrada de la carísima
fila es a ca 2 y así nos seguimos con
todas las columnas hasta que llegamos a
la enésima columna donde el vector
rk que es la que es y más fila tiene una
entrada a k n
que esté simplemente otra forma de
escribir a una matriz y bueno también
vamos a tener una matriz b que va a ser
una matriz de n por n también y esta vez
va a ser muy parecida a esta matriz a
pero va a tener un cambio muy importante
porque ahí tenemos la primera fila debe
que es igualita a la primera fila de a
lo mismo que la segunda fila y así nos
seguimos vamos a concentrarnos en estas
dos filas
y es más fila y la jota es una fila de
la matriz y el resto de las filas de la
matriz b van a ser exactamente iguales a
las filas correspondientes de la matriz
a de hecho leyes y más fila también va a
ser igual que entonces llegamos hasta la
décima fila
y después la jota es más fila de la
matriz b en lugar de ser igualita a la j
décima fila de la matriz a va a ser
igual a ponemos aquí
rj que es la jota décima fila de la
matriz a menos un escalar vamos a
ponerle se la décima fila de la matriz
r esta está dejando lo escribo por aquí
esta es la jota décima fila de la matriz
b j encima
j es una fila
y esta fila es la única fila de la
matriz b que es distinta de la matriz a
aunque hay entonces por aquí seguimos
hasta que llegamos a la fila n
y para que quede muy claro qué significa
este vector pues vamos a escribirlo con
todo detalle vamos a escribir cada una
de sus entradas entonces tenemos aquí rj
menos
y esto es igual al vector fila que
obtenemos al hacer esta operación ok y
esta operación tal cual que es es tomar
este vector multiplicarlo por un escalar
c o sea cada una de las entradas del
vector r y la vamos a multiplicar por c
y después al vector fila rj a cada una
de las entradas del vector
rj le vamos a restar la entrada
correspondiente del vector
cr y ok o sea la primera entrada del
vector que nos queda al hacer esta
operación es simplemente la primera
entrada de rj que es simplemente a j
1 - 0 veces
cbc es por la primera entrada del vector
r
ok o sea la entrada
la segunda entrada lo que tenemos es la
segunda entrada del vector
rj sea aj 2 - c veces por la segunda
entrada del vector r que es la entrada a
y 2 y así nos seguimos hasta que
llegamos a la enésima entrada y entonces
lo que tenemos es la enésima entrada de
este vector o sea a j n - c veces la
enésima entrada del vector r o sea a y n
y listo esta es la js fila de la matriz
b ok entonces b es la matriz que
obtenemos si tomamos a a y reemplazamos
la js bach fila por la misma j décima
fila menos c veces la décima fila de la
matriz a ok y creo que ahorita es cuando
seguramente estas recordando que ya
hemos visto esto un montón de veces en
un montón de vídeos por ejemplo este es
el tipo de operaciones que se hacen
cuando estamos tratando de reducir una
matriz a su forma escalonada reducida
por filas y bueno eso es simplemente una
de las esperas ciones más importantes
así es que naturalmente nosotros lo que
queremos es ver cuál es el determinante
de esta nueva matriz b que obtuvimos
haciéndole una operación de fila en la
matriz a y para hacer eso pues vamos a
considerar dos matrices
la primera matriz es r1 r2 y así todas
las pilas de la matriz hasta llegar a la
décima fila después la j es más fila y
finalmente la enésima fila ok en
realidad esta es simplemente la matriz a
ok tiene todas sus filas idénticas a la
matriz a pero la vamos a necesitar y
vamos a considerar también a esta otra
matriz la matriz
y tiene casi todas sus pilas iguales en
la matriz a excepto la cota décima fila
aunque aquí tenemos r1 r2 no seguimos
llegamos a la décima fila y ésta también
es igual a la de la matriz
pero después llegamos a la j es sin más
fila y en lugar de tener a rj vamos a
tener menos c veces r y ok de hecho creo
que lo tengo que poner de otro color
porque es muy importante o sea es la
única fila que es distinta entonces
vamos a ponerlo de otro color
- a veces r
y esta ésta es la jota es imagina ok j
sin fila de esta matriz ahora seguimos
hasta que llegamos a la enésima fila que
también tiene que ser igual a la enésima
fila de la matriz
y ahora es tiempo de recordar lo que
vimos hace unos cuantos vídeos y bueno
seguro recordarás este vídeo que nos
dice que si tenemos dos matrices que son
exactamente iguales en todas sus filas
excepto en una de ellas en este caso esa
fila es la jota décima fila y luego
tenemos otra matriz que es idéntica a
esas dos matrices excepto también justo
en la jota décima fila y además tenemos
que la jota décima fila de esta matriz
be o sea esta fila es igual a la suma de
las jota es y más filas de estas otras
dos matrices entonces el determinante de
esta matriz es igual al determinante de
esta matriz más el determinante de esta
matriz aunque ya hay que hacer hincapié
en que ve no es igual a esta matriz más
esta matriz
sólo la jota es y más fila debe es la
que es igual a la suma de la jota es y
más fila de esta matriz más la jota
décima fila de esta otra matriz y el
resto de sus filas son idénticas
ok pero bueno esto yo creo que hay que
escribirlo bueno al menos hay que
escribir que el determinante bebé es
igual a el determinante de esta matriz
más el determinante de esta otra matriz
aquí vamos a borrar esto porque nos
estorba
bien entonces lo que queremos hacer es
calcular estos determinantes aunque hay
pero esto de aquí es simplemente el
determinante de a no o sea porque esta
era simplemente la matriz a y ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es sacar este
determinante y para eso vamos a usar dos
vídeos que están en esta misma sección
que seguramente ya viste el chiste es
que este determinante es igual al
determinante de otra matriz ahorita
vamos a escribir la otra matriz esta
otra matriz va a ser r1 r2 así nos
seguimos hasta ere y después nos
quedamos por aquí y en la j es una fila
vamos a quedarnos simplemente con un ere
y ojo no es una re j ni tampoco es un
menos cr y simplemente un ere y hasta el
final seguimos con todas las filas igual
y tasa de estas filas hasta que llegamos
a la fila
no tenemos rn ok entonces en uno de esos
vídeos que seguramente ya viste lo que
vimos es que este determinante es
exactamente igual a menos c veces por el
determinante de esta otra matriz ok aquí
hay que hacer hincapié en que estamos
considerando simplemente este
determinante y que este determinante es
igual a ver vamos a ponerlo así este
determinante es igual a
este determinante ok a ver y por qué son
iguales
estos dos determinantes pues porque
tenemos que esta matriz es idéntica a
esta otra matriz excepto en una sola de
sus filas la famosísima j es más fila lo
que hay que en esta matriz la j décima
fila tiene como entrada menos c veces el
vector r
y en esta matriz la j décima fila es
simplemente la fila rey y en el resto de
las filas
estas dos matrices son exactamente
iguales entonces como vimos en ese vídeo
se da esta igualdad entre estos dos
determinantes ok
notemos que esta matriz no es menos de
veces esta matriz ok esta matriz es
igual y está en todas sus filas excepto
en la j décima fila donde la j es una
fila de esta matriz es menos c veces la
j es una fila de esta matriz
pero cuál es el determinante de esta
matriz bueno como seguramente ya te
diste cuenta esta matriz tiene es filas
duplicadas o sea la décima fila es la
fila ere y de la matriz a pero la j es
una fila de esta matriz también es
igualita a la décima fila de la matriz a
de estas dos filas son idénticas y por
lo tanto como vimos en el vídeo pasado
el determinante de esta matriz es igual
a cero ok entonces este determinante es
igual a cero y por lo tanto menos c
veces este determinante también es igual
a cero y como este determinante es igual
a menos de veces este determinante
entonces este determinante también es
igual a cero así es que a final de
cuentas nos quedamos con que el
determinante bb es igual
el determinante de la matriz a lo cual
está súper padre o sea lo que nos está
diciendo es que si tenemos una matriz
por ejemplo la matriz a y le aplicamos
esta operación de fila justo esta
operación de fila que se trata de
agarrar una fila y sustituirla por esa
fila menos un escalar multiplicando a
cualquiera otra de las filas entonces
el determinante de esta nueva matriz va
a ser igual al determinante de la matriz
original y eso sigue estando padrísimo
ahora muy importante estamos haciendo
justo esta operación de fila ok por
ejemplo si hacemos la operación de fila
que se trata de multiplicar una fila por
un escalar eso como ya vimos si cambia
el determinante pero bueno sigue estando
padrísimo porque eso puede hacer que
calcularon determinante sea mucho más
fácil